lots of questions in guessing here in
Germany are the Americans about to pull
thousands of troops out of the country
and if so why last week US President
Trump
reportedly instructed the Pentagon to
bring home almost 10,000 of the 34,000
troops stationed here in Germany the
Pentagon has not confirmed that report
and the German government says it has
not received notification ever since he
became US president Donald Trump has
criticized Germany for not increasing
its defense spending today Germany's
defense minister made it clear the
presence of US troops serves US
interests and does not constitute the
Americans doing the Germans a favor the
fact is that the presence of US soldiers
in Germany serves the overall security
of the NATO alliance and thus also
American security that is the basis on
which we work together incidentally it
is also the basis on which many American
soldiers have also become a real
component of German society are well
integrated on the ground and play an
important role there and in this respect
for today I believe there is no need to
add anything all right for more now
let's take this story to Brussels home
to NATO headquarters GWS teri Schultz
joins me now from our Brussels bureau
teri has spent many years covering NATO
good evening to you teri Germany says
that Washington has not announced
anything has NATO received word of any
troop reduction plans in Germany it's
hard to tell Brent I asked Secretary
General Stoltenberg about the u.s. plans
for withdrawing German troops today at
an at an online event he he held and
this is what he said we are constantly
consulting with the United States
with other NATO allies on the military
posture presence in in Europe European
allies in the United States we are doing
more together now in Europe and
for many many years I think that
reflects the the fact that we are
actually been able to strengthen the
military cooperation within NATO
velocities so Secretary General
Stoltenberg would not directly address
whether he had been informed about about
u.s. plans and in fact he held a phone
call with President Trump after this
event and even after this I asked NATO
officials again did they discuss the
reported plans to pull troops out of
Germany and I didn't get a straight
answer again simply was told that they
discussed the US troop presence in
Europe as they always do so we really
don't know Brent yeah frustrating for
you and for all of us trying to get
answers a trump administration official
told us that there is no need for a
large US presence in Germany because
NATO has increased its defense spending
is that true and is NATO just as strong
with fewer US troops here in Germany we
don't really know Brent
it is true that NATO has increased its
defense spending or more accurately that
that all NATO allies have increased
their spending on their own militaries
which is in fact usually referred to as
as NATO defence spending but they really
there really hasn't been a test of
whether NATO's need for US troops here
on the continent but I think what's
what's really missed in this
conversation is that it's in the US
interest to have the troops stationed in
Germany those troops are not there
simply to protect Germany as President
Trump likes to portrayed or even to
protect Europe in fact it is used as a
staging grounds for troops to go on to
other parts of the world I mean not even
not even Europe not even the Russian
border the USA has many uses for its
installations in Germany and that in
fact would be a huge loss and you saw
many commentators coming out after this
announcement saying that's a ridiculous
decision that's a strategic mistake
those are most of the comments I heard
from military commentators a mistake for
the United States not a threat to Europe
yeah a colossal mistake
we've heard in the last 48 hours you
know Terry there are worries here
Berlin that Donald Trump would reduce US
troop numbers to punish Germany for not
spending more on defense are those
worries are they justified based on what
you know about us NATO ties at the
moment well I think it's more about us
German ties in fact outside the NATO
context and I have also read those
reports that this is sort of another fit
of pique by President Trump about
Germany's low defense spending also
rumors that he was angry because
Chancellor Merkel refused to come to a
g7 summit at this point due to
coronavirus worries and that's had to be
delayed so we don't really know in fact
you know many in the administration were
not informed of the thinking behind
president Trump's reported decision to
do this and it was just asked at the
White House a short time ago today in
their briefing and they didn't have
anything to say about it either so he
has apparently kept this decision if it
is made in fact quite quite close and
nobody's really sure how he came about
but I wouldn't put it past him to to be
coming up with this idea to punish
Chancellor Merkel one of his frequent
targets Stoltenberg he is always quick
to talk up US commitments to NATO are we
to believe that after three years of the
trump presidency America's role in NATO
is stronger it is true as Secretary
General Stoltenberg likes to point out
massaging this message that despite all
the Trump threats to NATO the threats
that range from pulling out to simply
cutting off funding it is true that the
US troop commitment the US troop
presence in Europe is greater now than
it has been that it even was under
President Obama but that remains to be
seen whether whether that will continue
with these threats from President Trump
and whether it's true that there are
more boots on the ground or not what he
has done to shake up unity to make the
the allies constantly wonder what he has
up his sleeve next I don't know that
that makes up for having more US
soldiers on the ground here
yeah that's an important point that we
should not forget teri Schultz on the
story Ford's in Brussels tonight Syria
as always thank you